goodbye to gay sports coverage of e3
2015 oh my god all harmonics are here
Daniel Sussman Eric poke Nick Chester
how you doing gentlemen we great not
having me any more thrilled time yeah
you've got to sit down yes you have to
look around this stuff to every single
appointment make sure it works yes and
it does it cut of works there are some
calibration issues on our end so it's
all good we're gonna make it work you
guys but yeah you're got your you're
here and it's back Rock bound for its
definitely back better than ever better
than ever this has been a fantastic III
for us you know we're I think running on
fumes a little bit here we are day three
but oh my god it has just been it's been
awesome to bring rockband for two people
were set up on the concourse outside you
can see us all we're all like like
sunburned and yeah but it's just been
non-stop but you know it's like the
reception has been outstanding and and
we're thrilled well it's a game people
have been wanting to see back from
harmonix for a while what was it a bad
sort of now that made you think okay
actually enough time has passed let's do
it really there are two things one is
that you know we've been doing we've
actually been working on a lot of other
games over the last couple years and you
know we're very proud of that work but
but the reception is like oh that's
really interesting where's rock band 4
we know that there's a community of
people that are just dying for this and
we hear about it and so you know that's
that's one thing just knowing that
there's an audience is huge the other
pieces is actually more more interesting
we we really wanted to make sure that we
had something to bring to the category
creatively and and what we're going to
show here actually is sort of the
flagship of rock band 4 it's the the
Freestyle guitar solos which totally
energized our team you know we are we're
doing this and we're very excited about
the the new gameplay and you know you
think about rock band you know we
brought drums we brought vocals to the
category and and then really the
gameplay mmm it's kind of static you
know and and and really not a lot
changed in terms of you know the high
level principle it's like okay we're
telling you what to do you see if you
see a color tab you press a button and
with the free style guitar solos you're
making your own solo and its really
there's a lot of depth to the system
there's a lot of great gameplay in there
and
to new and you know there's it's
impossible they like not just play with
this [ __ ] eating grin on your face I
mean it's like it's joy inducing which
is why we're in the business so awesome
i want to see Nick [ __ ] eating yeah and
so let's get right into it let's show us
all about this this crazy new tech you
guys are putting because you guys are
clearly supporting a lot of the old
games it like that libraries all there
yep now there's controllers absolutely
let's have a look at the new so what
we're gonna do here this is actually
gonna cheat into a special mode of the
game where cheat with this suitable
intelligent device yes with this
cheating device comes with every copy of
rock band 4 and so this is going to
basically replace the track with you
know so that it can can solo over the
entire song and this gives us an
opportunity to just step through how how
the system works so wait what songs you
pick the warrior by scandal yeah all
right rock anthem we're going to shoot
through the walls of heartache bang bang
so here the songs going to start up and
superstar Nick Chester over here Nick
can play music so the first thing we'll
show you is you know you can play single
notes which is straightforward you hold
down a key and you strum
and everything is you know in the key of
the song the fancy year is that you are
a rock god right that you feel awesome
about what you're doing so even if you
don't know how this works you still
sound good you know it's like there's no
bum notes here and so there's a
different note with with each key you
can jump up to the high frets and
everything jumps up in octave there's a
tremendous amount of depth even while
you're just playing single notes you can
bend into the notes if you up strum
which is really cool yes there's there's
the city of better I got to be a hot
potato face there it is and then if he
holds down a board you know two or more
frets and then strums in tempo we
trigger these from eating licks and this
is where things start to get really fun
and there's actually there's a
tremendous amount of variety in here
there are tons of links that are mapped
to different chord progressions so he
can you can
yeah she's having a good ol time over
there and had if he strums fast it
actually doubles the the tempo of the
lake you start to get into these like
pyrotechnics you know it's like crazy
stuff starts happening and then he could
jump up to the high friends
everything shuts up an octave and off he
goes it's going crazy
just got to do this just all week yep
all right all right and so some of the
other stuff that's really fun is peeking
finger taps
get some like you know
nalin actually going right there
and then also we have all of this sort
of like super noisy guitar stuff and you
plays a single note until start to feed
back again at all resident you know and
great Margaret apply critical exactly
you know we're about the power slide
across the stage and so you know this is
basically these are all the different
components of your guitar solo this is
the bag of tricks that you have your
disposal
and when we play this in the context of
a of a regular song in the game we have
a visual language that we use to qu to
all of these different input modes all
right so you know if you see like a
single line down the middle of the track
that's play a single note if you see
this sort of checkerboard pattern that
gets bigger tap and even while we're
telling you sort of in broad strokes
what you should do you still have a
tremendous amount of creative control
over you know what notes you choose the
way and so it's you know we're not we're
not scoring you on your musicality right
you know we're scoring you based on you
know can you get from you know the low
notes to the high notes and then tilt
and then back down and actually there's
you know that what's been really fun is
watching all of these you know score
chaser you know like very competitive
rock band players come to this with sort
of
it's a blank slate really and there's a
game in there that's really fun and
engaging but it's new and so it's like
you know we're worse we're very happy
you know it's like we're happy to be
talking about it when did those moments
occur in the songs that do it end up
sort of reaching out for songs and
already have like solo parts in them
yeah so the way it works is when you get
to the guitar solo of a song you play
your own solo a kind of you know it's
the most logical thing to do and so a
free bird was to come on it'll be a case
of budget yeah like yeah just to clear
what we're doing right now is developing
cheap so it allows us to play over the
entire song
yeah show what it looks like in the
context of the song not to like restart
this so we you guys to just talk about
this is one of a bunch of things we
actually we've done a lot for the other
instruments as well we have a new form
of drum fills for the drummer cool we've
basically completely taken apart and put
back together the singing component rock
band 4 where you know one of the things
when we when we watch people play rock
band you know there's a lot of people
who like to sing they'll play on easier
medium because you just have more kind
of you have a larger window to be
expressive which is actually where the
fun is and when you start to play on
harder expert you have to sing pretty
quietly and match this little arrow up
with this note tube and that's not rock
and roll that's not that fun and so we
we basically built a system where you
could sing anything you want any
anything you want as long as you're in
the key of the song okay and yet you get
like an improv bonus and make up your
own lyrics you can make up your own
lyrics as long as you're just you know
singing in in key which you know is what
good singers can do you actually get the
score bump you know and so we're trying
to basically bring you kind of out of
your shell and you know give you the
tools that you need to be a charismatic
front person and you know I'm out of
here slate rock and roll here's Nick
taking a swing at it join himself so
this is the classic rock being gameplay
that you're all familiar with
yeah I think that's the other thing
that's actually you know when we we
played we played a lot of rock band but
quite sure I kind of calibration how
dimensions to say work and don't worry
we'll skip to the solo in a second show
you what that looks like oh I mean so
we're building on a really strong
foundation you know we we came back to
rock band and there was this sort of
moment of anticipation for me personally
where I was like is this game still
going to be fun you know it's like and
trust me I've logged my hours I have
played a lot of this game over the years
and it was it was awesome it felt really
good to come back and and you know and
and play a game that that was really fun
and at the same time you know we're
probably our harshest critics in a lot
of ways and and we were able to sort of
look at rock band 3 and no question some
of the calls that we made and you know
it's been a long road leading to this
moment we think rock band 4 is the
strongest game that we've ever that
we've ever made and is essentially the
like the Bert you guys are responsible
for the birth of the genre and for most
of its evolution as well and the other
thing that's super important for people
especially when it comes to these things
is the still having them like I'm sure
the price of these on ebay drums is
probably hopped back up again and always
up me when I hit that I think so Cabrera
signed in somehow manage all my goodness
yeah it won't be rockin roll of
something to [ __ ] up guys all right oh
yeah but yeah the fact that you guys
look backwards compatibility working on
all this as well backwards compatibility
for your hardware and for your DLC and
you know it's like it's funny it's like
we're very excited about strim you know
all of the new stuff that we're doing
but when we talk to our community the
thing that people care about the most is
the stuff that they have already bought
you know and so you you think about
people that have spent hundreds of
dollars on you know on DLC we absolutely
want to you know respect that investment
that people have made in their library
so ps3 to ps4 I don't have no idea
what's going on over there is going
great fine guys don't worry about us we
see our prototype hardware everything's
great keep talking we're all right and
then and then on the hardware to you
know if you have your if you have
guitars and drums they'll work with the
game are you guys making new ones your
partnership with my console yeah so what
so we're co-publishing with mad catz
they've been a phenomenal partner
actually they built all of this stuff
and
you know it's there still hard at work
you know ironing out the kinks but yeah
like the new stuff is great the build
quality is fantastic there's a lot of
improvements to kind of the sensitivity
of the drum heads the feel of the
buttons there's a new accelerometer in
there for the tilt the microphone
actually is a brand new microphone that
is it's just a better mic I mean it's
you know louder less distortion yeah a
charger you're putting the work in a
gentleman thank you so much for coming
on and when will be able when will we be
able to get our hands on rock band for
this year right this year so October 6
2015 and xbox one and playstation 4 2015
turned out to be pretty good year for
video games to turn a man not bad good
III yeah I'm not too bad thanks so much
for coming on guys and enjoy the rest of
your III all right 30 minutes of it or
whatever yeah thanks Evan us and thanks
to you for watching on case whoa calm on
their YouTube app as well and of course
on hitbox and we are done in terms of
the stuff that's going up on gamespot
for our live audience so stay tuned
we're gonna play some more of this